Disney logo alone now takes up 33
seconds of screen time followed by a
retro Disney logo that itself takes 16
seconds even the beginning narration
there was only oh shit
pretty sure at no time in Earth's
history was it only ocean science is
giving this movie the finger and I'm
right there with it some began to seek
defeat these odds voyage across the vast
ocean to take it how was he able to find
it was Maui just flying around until he
happened upon it and even if he did just
happen upon it did he assume since this
island vaguely looks like a woman on her
side in the fetal position that he was
in the right place and that assumption
was correct
not only does Maui have shape-shifting
abilities he has the ability to
transport whatever object he's holding
to the appropriate appendage of whatever
animal he shifts to he didn't have this
power he would have to store the heart
between his toes before transitioning to
a hawk so it would be in his hock
talents Maui tried to escape but was
confronted by another who sought the
heart what can I say its exposition
until every one of us is devoured by the
bloodthirsty jaws of death and that's
how grandma got fired as the daycare
teacher well as we stay on our very safe
Island won't be fine Moana recycles the
overprotective dad character arc from
Finding Nemo and thinks I won't notice
what soon ooh he is paradise who would
want to go anywhere else while the king
of this island debates isolationism with
his mother his diaper wearing toddler
was about to drown look sea turtles are
given one shot they either make it to
the water or they don't I'm not sure
that overly assisting this one baby is
actually helping anyone since he is weak
and will likely be killed at sea early
on if I were making this movie this is
where a dickhead Barracuda would show up
and eat that idiot turtle baby you
couldn't even reach the sea without help
from a human toddler thankfully for the
turtle I did not rate this movie here is
where the movie takes a very Moses like
turn although in this case instead of
God being behind the phenomenon it's
ocean god I think maybe it's honestly
not clear who's doing this or why
actually as the ocean gives her a new
hairstyle I'm left to wonder how wrong
everything I'm seeing would be if it
were another Hugh
doing it instead of the ocean hey you I
move on Oh what are you doing you scared
me she scared you you're the one who let
her wander out into the ocean and stay
there long enough to drown you big
asshole walk away man
Disney sure does love to age up
characters through song don't think
here's the bad influence grandma and
just like any movie before it you can
bet that she's more right than anyone in
this film who is not a bad influence
grandma you are the future of our people
Moana as much convention as this movie
box it's still another Disney movie
about a princess who doesn't want what
her destiny holds god damn how many
years is grandma Tala been dancing on
this beach she was out there for the
entire growing up montage baby the rock
Chippendale dancer kid here is super
inappropriate and suggests this Islands
males begin thinking about sex and
procreation at age eight have you ever
tried to crack a coconut I don't care
how rotten those things are they are
hardest there's no way this woman could
just pull this thing apart how traps in
the East Lagoon they're bullying up
listen this fish I'm sure we could we
fished beyond the reef no one goes
beyond the reef despite all science that
this land is dying mallanna's father
continues to refuse the ocean as an
option probably because of that whoever
that died that one time during that
flashback we've yet to see but still
it's stupid he took a canoe Maura is
here's the flashback I was talking about
we were in someone close to the chief
died and he got deathly afraid of ever
losing anyone again remind me again how
this is different from Finding Nemo his
best friend begged to be on that boat
your dad couldn't save him and therefore
all the ocean is evil makes sense also
this seems to be a pretty small village
if she knows everyone on the island
surely she knows the drowned man's
grieving family and should also have
heard this story many times before
and right here I'm going to praise the
film for a powerful song while also
shaming the film for having a current
pop singer cover this awesome song in
the credits I'd be giving us in back
here were it not for the doubly sinful
pop cover in the credits so sadly I'm
left to sit in this moment it's normal
because the movie is an idiot most
convenient guys are timing ever this
movie false starts the heroine see
adventure we all know is going to happen
anyway but we get several near misses
before she finally gets there Jesus it's
my wedding night all over again you had
a loose pig on a bamboo raft headed
toward waves what did you think was
gonna happen lady because of the stupid
pig Mohan is gonna get trapped
underwater by the screenplay which
desperately wants to give the father's
never leave the island arguments some
kind of reasoning or weight or I could
have just gone with inconvenient Coral
is convenient I don't even know why I
pool got on the boat to begin with pigs
hate water that's when I die I'm going
to come back as one of these literally
you've been told all out people's
stories but what the one about us being
boat people that either your father
entirely forgot about or refused to tell
you all because he had a buddy died in
the ocean one time what's in there the
answer to the question you keep asking
yourself also boats look if you want to
erase your people's voting history and
become island dwellers afraid of the
water how hard is it to just dispose of
the old boats bamboo and fabric just
light a fire boom no more evidence for
precocious daughters to find case closed
these boats have been in here for a
thousand years and even though they've
been behind a waterfall this whole time
they're in perfect condition bang the
truth grandma did say bang the drum but
despite the two sticks on top this looks
nothing like a drum grandma should have
been more specific said bang the upside
down all wood horsey saddle lookin Fang
also at the risk of sounding cynical an
anti ghost music how the fuck does
playing these old ass moisture log drums
wake up the fire ghosts and give her
literal visions of her ancestors
[Music]
[Applause]
so basically this cave was an ancestral
YouTube video waiting for someone to
enter the cave banging the drums and
then all would be revealed do I have
that right because that is way more
ridiculous than I remember it being when
I saw this movie in the theater this
movie does flirt with the mystical given
the glow a manta ray grandma on that
whole island as a person ending but
still this cave seems like the easy cave
of plot driving information hi the ocean
chose you well if the ocean is the smart
and omnipotent how did it ever get
consumed and defeated by defeated ending
and why does it need granny's help also
why doesn't the ocean just grab Moana
and send her straight to Maui without a
boat burn those boats a long time ago I
mean what you're the sea hating-ass
motherfucker on the island and you knew
about the cave ancestor boats and you
let them be were you waiting for someone
to find them why didn't you burn them a
long time ago it's your father
thankfully the chief is stopped from
burning the canoes by his mother's heart
attack wait one person who should be
dead already finds the strength to
expose it all over the hero with a word
bath of instructions cliche carries no
way you could go that I wanna be with
you hey am I the only one that remembers
a few minutes ago when this diagram I
could barely speak
now she's an expositional fountain the
mom who barely qualifies for her
character in this movie decides to help
send her off even though I have no
reason to believe that she has any clue
why Milano is leaving Oh does she know
how to sail this thing movie doubles
down on non-existent Fisher
constellation alan tudyk voicing an
idiot chicken is the best thing about
this movie and would also be the best
thing about literally any movie once and
on Nextup mouth if your only indication
of where to go or the star is shaped
like a hook in the sky then how she's
supposed to navigate during the day keep
in mind mallanna has never sailed a boat
in her life maybe don't go sailing until
you actually have sailing skills just a
thought the storm went from on the
horizon to on top of her in about three
seconds
Looby tries to make you think the
character the film is named after just
died but movie is pretty delusional on
that point if you ask me
dear movie showing us the chicken first
kills all the suspense that mallanna
might not have lived through the
mallanna is untouchable got it thanks
for the chicken jokes thankfully the
ocean storm deposited her at exactly the
place she was hoping to find what are
the odds never mind don't tell me the
odds I don't want to know we the ocean
confirms Moana suspicions that this is
Maui's Island in part because all those
maui fish hook doodles weren't enough
and in part because Moana is really
fucking stupid I'm here of course of
course yes now he always has time for
his fans
Maui has apparently been marooned here
for like a thousand years and she still
thinks the first person he sees and all
that time is a fan seeking an autograph
either battery's had tons of visitors
here seeking autographs and just never
stole their boats to leave the island we
can't play this song but the rock is a
way better movie musical singer than
Russell Crowe but that doesn't mean he's
good he's at least on pitch
he's passable that's cinebulle the rock
sings about killing and burying its guts
and somehow a coconut tree grew from it
this movie is really playing fast and
loose with evolution why is Bolin
enjoying this
she was legit angry a second ago but a
song turns her around and this song is
she even listening to the lyrics this is
the cockiest song ever huh Maui's
conscience is his tattoo why would you
even try this and now I'm going to love
you in my belly
sorry movie in mah belly is a registered
trademark owned by Mike Myers for you
the character fat bastard you want to
get seed let's batten you up drumstick
[Music]
but also Maui has already mentioned
eating this chicken soon a couple times
so exactly how fast does he think a
chicken can fatten up basically the
ocean in this movie is an ex machina
fate God love and irony all rolled into
one giant cop-out this is my canoe and
you journey this movie steals the gruff
adult male has to put up with a child
companion he wants nothing to do with
thing from well a bunch of movies but
for now let's go with Bad Santa are you
afraid of her why is Maui scared of the
heart now I want to show to to him a few
minutes ago and he didn't seem even
remotely scared of it okay look I really
enjoyed this movie I did but this odd
monkey coconut pirate side quest is
fucking crazy as balls and not a good
way I know we're dealing with gods and
demigods but I reject the notion that it
means we also have to deal with monkey
like coconut pirates I reject that
firmly also do those coconut monkeys
fucking smell the heart of defeat II is
that how that works
mallanna is suddenly eggsy from the
Kingsmen movie now he pilots this boat
out of danger like it has a motor or -
point is it's a sail based boat that
couldn't possibly go from zero to 30
knots like this movie suggests seriously
I can't assign if alan tudyk was
overpaid for this voice role or
underpaid he does so little but it's
also awesome
that's three since removed so far and
they're all tudyk due date oh look the
omnipotent ocean nubbin is back great
anyone has my hook it's that beady-eyed
bottom-feeder and we don't have time to
be wrong about that this movie has to be
over in like 45 minutes okay first I'm
not a princess I'm the daughter of the
chief so contradicting yourself away
finder it will never be wait
this ocean doesn't thing is really
driving the plot look I can get down
with an all-knowing ocean helping the
want to succeed not really but for the
sake of this sin let's just pretend it's
true but I cannot get down with the same
all-knowing ocean understanding the
concept of high five why does mallanna
even understand what a high five is
you're measuring the stars not giving
the sky a high five still confused as
hell why you even know what a high five
is next thing you'll be fist bumping an
elbow pounding like Bart Maguire in the
current swarm you're going the right way
it's cold wait it's getting warmer look
that was just a pee in the ocean joke
thanks wreck first somehow rubbing off
on Maui white people didn't send me the
ocean did the ocean make sense
you literally watch the ocean put her in
the boat a few times dick the ocean
straight up kooky dooms now he would be
excellent at cinema since Yoshi chose
you for our freezer if you start singing
I'm gonna throw up
so the guy who sang a song within the
first two minutes he was on screen you
know the realm of Monsters is a lot less
scary when you realize it's also the
realm of ex machina because maui
basically ignores her down here yet she
frequently doesn't die buried within
this batch insane shiny grab song is the
character detail that Maui's mother
tossed him in the water holy that's dark
Jesus I got something shiny for you hot
off 250
wait earlier the monkey coconut pirates
knew she had the heart of defeat he
simply because she took it out of its
case they smell their sense that it's
magical but here the evil black light
loving crab thinks she's holding up the
heart by sight because it's not
actually the heart so my point is
basically this is this heart mystically
identifiable or not hey hey did you like
the song not particularly would have
been better if it were Bret McKenzie now
I sing something about being dead soon
which is hilarious but I'd like to point
out that this asshole went from the
cockiest demigod ever to a humorous
fatalist in about 20 minutes time man's
discovery of nunya what's nunya I'm your
business
2017 movie proudly displays 1950s era
joke why does she even fucking need Maui
the ocean is clearly doing all the heavy
lifting here they threw me into the sea
like I was nothing
yes the movie is repeating this super
horrible backstory but it's also super
horrible kind of too heavy for this
light of a movie so once in for a movie
that just had a gilded singing crab
showpiece trying five minutes later to
hit me in the gut with literal child
tossing somehow I was found by the gods
somehow they gave me the hook why
because you were an ocean orphan that
was super vain did have any reason for
rewarding you this hook other than your
being abandoned movie decides to spend
time with Maui's tattoos basically does
save money on the animation budget for a
while since nothing these tattoos show
us seems to matter after one 5-minute
confidence boosting conversation Maui is
able to properly use this hook again
even the ocean is tired of keeping track
of this stupid chiken - hands in the
water both gauging for warm pee if the
movie has taught me anything
I mean sure he's bonded with Milan on a
tiny bit lately but still I did Maui
agree to risk his life on this quest
again this looks dangerous as I assumed
take ah built this barrier around the
island so why would she leave one small
passageway open did Galen or so helped
design it
somehow Milan's mistake of misjudging
distance cost Maui his hooks power
somehow and yet I'm confident that it
won't matter and the good guys will
still win because Disney now he only
flies away here so we can Han Solo back
into the climax later sorry but it's the
truth too many minutes of the movie
acting like Moana is actually gonna quit
what is that
a giant ghost looking electric-blue
manta ray why my grandma said she'd
returned as a manta ray is it possible
that I don't dare hope that I mean you
know a long ways past the reef ghost
grandma pulls a dream Clooney from
gravity and I am not pleased
those tucking she stands apart from the
crowd ghosts singing in preparation for
this stunt Tom Cruise actually swam down
this distance to retrieve a mock heart
of defeat II but was shocked to learn
he'd been recast as a teenage female and
lost the part to an authentic Island
actress now he apparently not only
taught
wayfaring he taught her to do it while
under fire from a literal lava monster
which is to say he taught her too damn
good for the time allotted there's no
reason to be nervous about mana dropping
in the heart in the ocean because the
ocean will just give it back so stop
trying to make that a tense thing movie
you came back now he pulls the Han Solo
move that everyone I anticipated he
would pull why am I just now realizing
that Moana is doing all this barefooted
those lava rocks can be sharpish so the
bottoms are her feet must be on scarred
and blistered after this adventure
Claire Dearing has nothing on mallanna
movie totally rips off the odd parting
of the sea thing from Prince of Egypt
also movies climax basically rips off
the black widow lullaby from age of
Ultron I'm honestly surprised they
didn't eat the pig while she was gone
since they couldn't catch any fish if
it's Locka ever since cinemasins began
the most requested thing has been TV
since and now it's a reality click the
link in the description below to check
it out and now the audio outtakes
[Music]
imagine a Asian it - fear nahan okay
send attract oi a logic assume I'm a
vegetarian are my